were you just satisfied with commercial
films did you when was it that just
decided to do something different
hi Wayne people just grow up after
growing up - ho ho what you pay voice of
on phone Queen only depends case what is
the sort of a [ __ ] piensa sir working
country towel it into the pay period on
here being white along here so you go
hold on the sense that we should when
you know it's a toy to good so i first
decided that i would not go down this
world after I made the taiwanese film or
growing up and was basically the movie a
boys from phone boy that's the turning
point for me that was a moment I've
decided that I'm gonna do something
different and in fact what I was doing
was different enough that even a DP the
cinematographer on the film he didn't
really quite know what to do with me or
the kind of stuff I was doing um what
did you want to do different just you
can the [ __ ] PAHO pongos Egan Powell
just haven't been a guitar Carla's a
guitar took a location watching what she
you know chooses we gender she can pan
then uses a condom a guitar piping a
won't reach in or kind of look at her
face and she one person potala down to I
think the thought first occurred to me
when I visited pom whole island which is
off the coast of Taiwan that's where the
film was set and I first went there was
actually an accident because I actually
went there - there's a filmmaker friend
a colleague who was also having a
production there at the time and I
didn't really know a whole lot it just
kind of went and checked it out now Yoko
are Saints tangle teezer worms
what you saw Thomas super gentle so
territory easy to do doc wait out to
landing consider the concerns awakened
former so in fact when I was making boys
from funk away I was talking to my DP at
rancor hall and at the time my one
direction that kept repeating to Sherman
Hall was just pull back further pull
back further pull back further and after
the production was finished we went back
to a central motion picture corporation
which is the company that produces film
and chung-ho the DP basically went to
the higher-ups there and set to them I
think OSHA has gone crazy I think he's
mad what's interesting about that is
that over the years I mean you are
famous for your for a camera that can be
distant I have heard different
explanations of why one explanation is
that it was a way of being kind to
actors who weren't really professionals
and weren't very good so there's less
pressure on them the other is that it's
rooted in Chinese aesthetics are either
are both of those true in Tecate it was
a failure and some question so in a year
can Joe Nickell Chino engine and I'm a 1
G so you Tom do yes so the first reason
is because I was working with a lot
non-professional actors at the time so
if you pull it back further the camera's
not there they're less aware of the fact
that there is a camera so they could act
in a more natural fashion um also those
early films I mean the films like time
to live in time to die
have a lot of very elaborate
choreography the camera stays in one
place but the people are constantly
moving around in you know in the frame
did that take a lot a long time to plan
out
what would you do by lid I don't
remember having rehearse anything what
hold on Pythian just gonna be on say
mountain yeah Naruto Lee yes normally I
basically just give the actors a general
idea of what they're doing but once they
enter into the film like I let them do
whatever they want they figure it out
themselves tenses donggeun with my
forehead Hong Shi Peters watching TV and
therapy n now you're going to LAN Chi
Tom P bar happens at T tau you have a
tool and she don't like a donkey and
opens it up so even though I would not
rehearsed but sometimes I would hide
actually intentionally plant stuff
within the film so for example you know
we thought the actors knowing sometimes
someone would suddenly come over this is
all planned someone was selling come
over and kick over a bicycle for example
so these sudden movement that would
shark that would jolt the actors out of
their complacency so to speak and that's
a way for me to direct and they didn't
know that this was gonna happen
no silly Avenger cheat on to the ha
workin to be enchanted couldn't avenge
elderly ambient Jang Wooyoung so if I
was doing a fighting for example it's a
fight scene between two sides I would
talk to them individually and I tell
them different things so then there's
conflict
um over the years did that did your
approach change I mean certain films
like flowers of Shanghai or your
beautiful new film the assassin seemed
they must have been planned more what
tippins's twindom what attendant pay it
on she is abide by now who took a so
guys just can mock lead time [ __ ] quick
wait ow
it's anger shaquita no I quit oh he took
a short so I thought to ketosis
passenger states got some clothes so
include country though hot here the
neighborhood even some just started so
it was saying gee keeping some juices
the type of the cathode so in a be no
say entire so we wait to unquote you you
so Linda you don't are well so for me
flower of Shanghai was particularly
difficult
what we did was at the time I had Mark
Lee plan least dolly tracks on the set
and the reason I wanted to do that to be
able to move around and zooming and now
their pen around the reason I want to do
this because the author who really
original source material on which really
was based on he was off that era and he
knew that world very well he spent a lot
of time in that actual world the world
of the courtesan brothel house so in a
way we wanted the camera itself to be
like the author that is an observer
someone was actually situated in that
context in that world